[Music]
in fatal sitting news Oh snaps yeah
sounds like you're the toilet submitted
by Mari hello Mary he'll hear a
300-pound woman pled guilty to killing
her boyfriend by sitting on him oh he
wasn't that smothering [ __ ] that's why
yes you said it like I had to do - me
too
[Laughter]
watching Oh squashing of course you know
there's a John R warns of really big
obese women on really skinny guys see it
they just literally stand on top of them
and then they drop on them yeah 300 some
odd pounds she trying to kill her
boyfriend because he was like doing
something wrong or was this like a like
you know how people die from that at
fixie eight you like you know that goes
too far
was this a sex act gone too far or was
she just like jumped on him like man and
he killed his ass I know she's about to
drop the ball on us right now yeah you
know yeah so this story's about Wendy
and key know that both 44 she's three
hundred pounds he was 120 pounds
whoa and so what happened here is that
this is a stereotype I know you see the
picture right black guy with a fat white
girl why can't it be a sumo wrestler in
like that Norwegian [ __ ] you're just
digging up all Katt Williams pictures
it's just so funny to write what you
said it was already in my head all right
so what happen is she was drinking she
was pretty drunk
by the time Keane oh god
he or she wanted of course she was
drinking alizée promptly oh she wanted
some crack worse and worse and more
funny thing is I've never seen a fat
crackhead you beat me yeah you're gonna
say yeah a 300-pound crack it laughs
when you committed to being fat I know
cause it's hard as [ __ ] that commitment
yeah yeah yeah it's crack or meth can't
even crack guy can't help you're pretty
and I've never met anyone that gets the
munchies on crack know what happened
wait wait first of all we get that we
can't let him just get away with that
[ __ ] how many people are you hanging out
with a lot of friends in high school
that were addicted to crack yes I lived
in downtown yeah now downtown
so it's entire like observational
scenery is kind of like a lot of
interesting characters mm-hmm all right
so what happened here she wanted some
crack somehow that led to an argument
between the two of them and said yeah we
want crack you gotta get your crack yeah
so she got a knife stabbed him in the
hand
oh [ __ ] table leg well that's what
killed over the head then she sat on him
and his chest
anyway she pushed him she meant to
murder his she's have you intentions
yeah everything else was very mild like
very extreme compared to the [ __ ]
sitting part I think the breaking the
table are you smashing it over his head
was the hard part
that's probably what we can to though
yeah in the hand with a knife she wanted
to kill him yeah yes we've been together
for two years and now the sister quino's
sister was saying like man you know I
even told her once I don't kill my
brother what kind of [ __ ] town is
this dude that's funny that's funny how
she's like I warned him that she's gonna
kill it if you know someone's gonna kill
your
Vania I've been iary Billy is it
prettier yeah it's funny because I just
picture uh what do you call it the Amish
people across the street just like
judging mmm this is why we don't do
crack anyway we have this [ __ ]
guilty to third-degree murder because
right after she killed them she called
the cops and said uh for some reason I
picked her a voice very high-pitched ooh
I don't know why you don't say she
doesn't look that fat I think it was
that's why it was the the clubbing and
yeah probably so if he was knocked out
and she sat on his face picture him
being on his chest the booty was
probably still like we was how was she
facing was her black hole in his face
like he weighed like a buck ten though
he was out he was 120 he's 120 yeah I'm
surprised he wasn't as like he wasn't
faster than her you know like he could
dodge it like what then he probably
probably underestimated her that she had
a crack species stabbed them in the
hands like by one side oh my god it's a
terrible way to die
obesity kills y'all it's a great
commercial
I know his death was ruled a homicide
caused by a respiratory insufficiency
secondary to blunt-force trauma to the
neck and thoracic compression shake it's
work
but yeah so yeah now she's so the sister
is also angry because her sentence was
lessened by a little bit from 20 to 40
years it was down to 18 36 years because
she confessed and like she was oh but
you really upset about those 4 years 4
years
no her sister wanted her to get life
yeah but this is she's coming it's like
life at that point man 18 years in
prison
she's already 44 she'll be what you know
to mean she's gonna be 70 which is the
principle of it all like I just I want
to know that life she's gonna be there
the entire time she's gonna die and rot
in that so yeah but life only means
life's 25 years but she also pretty low
was also like hey don't kill my brother
so she's that to have a person so she
thinks it could be for real
well she I think she should be thinking
about like I knew this woman was gonna
kill then you take a little
responsibility there to you don't I mean
yes oh keno is survived by his daughter
two grandchildren every stereotype you
can find is this crazy kids total in
that 50 hat collection she's gonna last
longer in jail the door of the wall yeah
probably because if she was like on
crack and living to be queen
you can't stay fat like that in jail
either no they don't have enough food
yeah what's just regimen she's gonna
work out yes you know come out of jail
yeah a better person Laurie and be like
when I was big you didn't want me now
I'm all hot she looks like that chick
that was on Maury that that she was on
five times trying to find out who the
father of her baby
yeah yeah I hate that show and the baby
came out completely white and he was
surprised
hey we know someone like that who on a
sauce that his dad's like black and his
mom is white and he looks white as [ __ ]
he's got like babies come out sometimes
they did not that's picture that's gotta
be your nightmare as a dad right as a
husband you know you're in the operating
room you know well you'll be like a five
minute operating room and they're like a
Chinese baby came out I'd be like that's
how you find out your chick cheated on
you imagine like you know you guys like
a black baby comes out you're gonna be
like looking at her like what the hell
like what do you do like what do you
leave the hospital like if a black baby
comes out do you leave the house think
it's like reverse albino hell yeah it's
like we it's like reverse albino instead
of a completely wife's like you just
leave like it would you just be like is
that my kid before fine man that be oh
my god I'm sure that's happened yeah
tell the dad to come together yeah
that'd just be like such a terrible way
to baby and run wait well I hate when I
do that online that was about what still
the black baby and run from his white
girlfriend kind of make super-soldiers
related to you yeah you're gonna be
arrested well it's a black it's a black
baby so they're gonna have better
genetics than me but you just stole a
baby that's not yours that's fine no
one's gonna know that it exists yeah
besides the hospital the doctor they
pulled it out and the nurses and they
carried my mind it's work and I'm gonna
train him too
be an assassin and I'm gonna make money
off of the baby okay
who's he gonna kill important people Oh
like politicians up on that plan drug
laws the worst I said this is the worst
like Yakuza story black kid who's like
you know trained as a ninja he was
stolen from the hospital from a cheating
mom and at the very end he's gonna find
out what I did and he's gonna kill me
you know what I know that's a great
movie but you killed yourself I haven't
seen this man I haven't seen like dudes
where do rags out in public anymore
I don't see anymore Cisco does also go
to those parts of town anymore
yeah you've elevated dude she just
called you bougie a little bit cuz I
clutch my purse real hard now yeah
when's the last time you stepped in to a
swap meet
dude like oh my god he goes to a couple
truck I know I own that that's the
difference no I go back to Mike my
hometown and his hometown where about
Sacramento and there's like certain
spots I used to kick it at I'll feel
safe Rob me because like I can't believe
I wasn't one of you people you [ __ ]
disgusting creatures like judging the
[ __ ] out of them dude like I made it out
of here
No [ __ ] savages you should roll with
you man you go back to your parents
store judging all the customers that's
what my parents do I feel really
comfortable like this cuz I grew up
there my parents are like a black bean
spy store and so I used to a beauty
supply store yeah and so a lot of money
in that they depending and if they have
those mega stores but a lot of those mom
and pops are going out now just because
like Walmart has like a lot of this
stuff now too and pile online yeah yeah
I say malls and stuff are about to close
if you come to the personal businesses
because you develop relationships and
you hook them up you know so if you like
customers like you
if you have half off yeah how it is but
I missed that place do you miss being a
you risk being in Sacramento yeah I love
Sacramento it's just not not the parts
are used to hang out in there's like a
whole part of Sacramento that's really
nice I love that part I didn't know
about I could picture myself I went
there recently so my friend Lucy it like
I realize how ghetto I work that's
really what it was so like we would kick
it in these spots at all like I'm like
this is what Sacramento is but that's
not it's only like 20% of it and the
other 80% is actually really nice so
much of white people in Sacramento like
I had no [ __ ] idea you know and so my
best friend because he moved to Midtown
downtown got Midtown and then we grew up
in South Sacramento wait but you we are
you saying you lived in the bad Asian
neighborhood cuz I don't usually it's
usually where the white people are the
Asian people are right there not in
Sacramento Sacramento is like highly
diverse so like you know like how LA is
diverse but there's different pockets of
people Sacramento is everybody's mixed
and not all Asians are the same yeah
ladies I know you got no no nobody
within the Asians you got broke ones you
got some Asians they come from like
war-torn countries [ __ ] up and then
some Asians they came here because they
were like a professor or something
exactly so there's like or they sent
their one kid at a time to go to school
then they got a job like the
billionaire's
yeah now and I just see you 16 year-old
Chinese kids with Lamborghinis and [ __ ]
[ __ ] those kids man
[Music]